joining us right now is our buddy my
longtime colleague from the nfl
network an nfl media group who then
moved on to greener cbs
sports pastors and he is the insider for
the nfl today on cbs he's my buddy jason
lochenfora how are you jason
what's going on homie well uh you tell
me
what's uh what's the latest uh um in the
2020 playing season and how it might be
somewhat threatened by covet 19. what's
going on yeah well you guys were just
talking about eight baseball games today
and
i guess the french open is going on
right now and we've got
uh golf majors that will be going on
through
the fall and winter and you know that
this
term the new normal right what does that
mean and how
are all these different sports entities
affected and
luck but nothing sort of a miracle
the numbers in the nfl in terms of the
covid reserve list and what we entered
week three with one player in the entire
league
through three weeks who'd been placed on
it um
maintaining those numbers would seem to
be uh
statistically improbable if not
impossible and we're now at a point
where
um the titans have an issue and
uh we'll see what the numbers look like
moving forward and obviously they're
they're doing everything in their power
um
to keep the number of of of cases as low
as possible
but in the interim you know the league
and has to
and the pa have to sort of make
contingencies so
you know at a time when we have all
these different sports things going on
as i just mentioned
you know a tuesday night game or
wednesday night game like
does that really seem all that odd you
know considering everything else
that that we've watched in the sports
landscape considering
you know an nba season continued in
one location in orlando and then an
entire playoff played down there and you
know the nhl and what edmonton and
toronto
uh so yeah everybody's got to adapt
everybody's got to remain malleable and
everybody's got to try to do their part
um
you know to to be to to abide by all
these regulations or protocols
and try to keep the numbers down but
there were going there were always going
to be
positive tests and outbreaks to some
degree i mean again just
think about how much humanity is
involved in the average workday in the
average
nfl training facility and so now we'll
see
you know we'll see how things look day
by day
and and what makes the most sense and
whether they could play monday or
tuesday or whatever else
but also bear in mind these stadiums
aren't being used for anything else
you're not dealing with sponsors you're
not dealing with fans
you're not having to refund tickets by
and large yes there's a few places that
they're playing to
a very small number um but
but not you know not not involving this
game
so to play a game on a tuesday or
wednesday or in the middle of a day in
the middle of the week if you had to
and then the next week have those teams
do it again because again like
there's no taylor swift concert there's
no tractor pull you're
you're you really kind of are able to
have a degree of flexibility
from us from a a planning and scheduling
standpoint unlike anything we've seen
jason lock and forward here on the rich
eisen show so then there's two questions
um is what now as you just we're
beginning to address and then
how do we prevent it from happening uh
elsewhere or
again so let's stick with a little bit
of the of the what now
um and um and on that front
i guess they're just looking at positive
tests um
that's what they're going to wait to see
and and then how many how long
is this something that's being that
emanated from our building or
or or emanated from a bus that we were
all alone together or
not all of us because now that's
multiple buses right because you've got
one guy per row and um was it on a plane
you know was it at the hotel um
and just trying to gain as much insight
into that as you can because that
obviously helps you
you know prevent it from happening again
and then
know how many people okay well if it was
a bus or was it bus one was it bus two
was it bus three who else was on that
bus and
you know uh in terms of preventing it i
i don't i mean i'll just say what i said
before i think it's an absolute miracle
that
you know aj tyrell was the only guy in
the league on a coveted list
through an entire training camp i'll be
a truncated but still they were in these
buildings for six weeks right
and then through three weeks of play
but just the numbers of what's going on
in this country and what's going on in
many of these communities where
these guys go home and their kids are in
school and some of their wives work
and you you could follow every tenet of
the law like here in baltimore you know
bradley bozeman they're starting left
guard
has a foundation they're feeding they're
getting 21 000 meals at a church
every other tuesday he and his wife
nikki have never been there to actually
take part in it
because they're not allowed to be around
more than 10 people you know so they've
got no zoom robots that the ravens sent
down there
and as the people are picking up their
meals they've got brad and nicky on
either side on the screen
but like they're not leaving their house
just because you know everybody's trying
to
like everybody's doing can do the right
thing
society isn't in a bubble and they're
not in a bubble and
it's inevitable that things are going to
come up no doubt about it jason don't
target even with a mask on or whatever
i'm sure you saw though
um what is the league going to do about
and again it's so difficult to bring
this up because it is
and it was a charitable venture i'm sure
you saw many of the las vegas raiders
out and about waller messed up others
not
uh at an event for him i mean
what does the league do about that they
come down hard i think part of the
reason you haven't heard
um about the the raiders and the the
personnel
who were in the locker room who didn't
have the proper clearance weren't in the
tier
that you need to be in to be in a locker
room and then this
i i i suspect that that the league will
come down
heavy i mean they sent the memo today
saying repeat offenders are subject to
suspension and
loss of drastic i reported on the nfl
day sunday morning that that was
that's where the league was and that
if the fines aren't working then we'll
find other ways to get your attention
i mean they haven't had this discussion
formally yet but talking to individuals
in the league office
could not wearing a mask at some point
become a 15-yard fine on the spot
i mean they're not there now but
if this continues i i will at least be
discussions
about how do we get people's attention
and if
the money's not enough then we'll try
taking you off the sidelines for a week
or we'll take away one of your draft
picks and if that's not enough
then maybe it's got to be 15 yards like
maybe then you'll see coaches wrapped up
like mummies on the sidelines i i don't
know
um and again is that is the face mask on
the sideline for those three hours the
end-all and be-all
i get it for the people who would say no
but i also know
that they made promises to mayors and
governors in a lot of these cities to be
able to
get this many people together not even
including fans but the five or six
hundred people it takes
to get the game on to bring them
together
we promise they're all going to wear
face masks hey nfl pa we're in this
together we collectively bargained
yeah yeah our coaches and our staff are
going to wear the face mask
you know when you're not wearing a face
mask the
you you know the league made promises
the league made assurances collectively
bargained and otherwise
they don't like to see them broken for
the whole world to see
for you know three hours every sunday
jason locking four of cbs sports here on
the rich eisen show in the couple
minutes i have left with you
um let us go uh talk some football you
mentioned baltimore you've got
a radio show that you do there every
single day
um what do we take out of the monday
night
loss to kansas city where once again a
halftime deficit
was not overcome and that this offense
you know you put enough
uh games together that uh
dewey glean that this offense and
quarterback um
has trouble when they're down by more
than one score
jason i i mean that's certainly not the
ideal scenario for them there's no doubt
about that and they haven't collectively
figured out a way
to deal with it now if you if you dig
down on each of these games and you kind
of
watch them again or you look back
through the playbooks
they're often their own worst enemy i
mean they run six times for 60 yards on
the opening drive it's first and 15 in
the red zone
pass pass pass chip shot field goal next
drive
pass pass pass next duvernay touchdown
to the house 13-10
defense has been on the field all day
what do you think they'll do
wrong pass pass pass six
carry 60 yards lamar two for 35
they run 18 offensive plays the rest of
the half rich not including penalties
three runs only one by lamar and 15
passes
you know gus edwards is 10 yards a carry
touched the ball four times pat ricard
freaking nature fullback was on the
field for over half their snaps against
the texans
he was on the field for 16 running plays
the previous week they gained 134 yards
in those 16
plays on the ground how many snaps do
you think he played monday night 11.
so i mean that's a big part of it and
they change their spots too quickly when
they get behind they ran back into the
game in the third quarter
and then it's a one you know they get it
to be a one a one score game again and
the defense just has no answers for
for mahomes but uh they stopped running
the ball early on the chargers and
didn't use heavy personnel and the
playoff loss they went empty set
in a one score game to start the second
half a second quarter in the second half
against the titans
no fullback no jumbo packages
it didn't work so well i mean they did
it in arrowhead last year and they did
it again last night i hear you jason but
i mean it just it seems to me and again
i'm not there
like you are uh before you go national
um it seems to me that there is no
[Music]
i guess dependable receiving threat for
lamar
that's going to make a play for him and
catch the ball for him
um that there's no there's no deandre
like look there's not not everyone has a
deandre hopkins
but there's nobody that's just gonna
definitely get open when they need to
and there's nobody's gonna make that
play andrews might be the closest they
have to somebody like that
well hollywood brown has to be that guy
right he took him in the first round
last year he played it about 70 percent
had the plate in his foot
he's not on a pitch count this year he
and lamar live close to each other in
south florida they
played they were throwing the ball
around literally the entire
pandemic um you know he was working out
with antonio
his cousin he put on 20 pounds of muscle
i mean he's jacked up
he stole as fast as ever he showed up a
little bit in the first
game against the the the browns um
but not much since and that's a problem
andrews has had two bad drops in that
game
they somebody else has to emerge boykins
a blocking wide receiver it's not going
to be him
they took devin duvernay in the third
round he has elite speed he took that
kick to the house
he only played seven reps on offense um
caught one ball i expect that to change
they need him in the slot to be a force
willie sneeds a nice nfl receiver
nobody's worried about really speed
beating them there has to be another
option that develops if it's not
internally then
maybe that's through free agency or
trade but but
you know they took a couple receivers in
this draft and they're hoping that over
the course of the season
they emerge last one for you jason we're
already talking about hot seats
uh the jets on thursday night football
0-3 here's a kid who's never started
coming out of boise state who's never
had a player start in the nfl
short week on the road for denver
jets lose this one to go 0-4 is it
possible the
the jets for the first time and did the
johnson administration make a change
midstream what do you got for me it's
possible
yeah i mean it's it's possible i i mean
the reality there is i i don't see them
returning as presently constituted in
2021
under any circumstances one way to put
it um is woody back from the uk
in the middle of november or december i
i don't know
that's possible uh what's going on there
is untenable
and the their their ownership regime has
has not
uh been marked by a lot of success and
they haven't really done a lot of things
that you would lend you to
um believe that they're going to be uh
cohesive and together and there's always
been tension
um so i would expect more of the same i
don't believe
from what i've heard that it's you know
there's some stuff going around about he
loses this game they're actually going
to fire him the next day
i i have not heard that but he just set
the game up i mean if you if you can't
beat this team
who can you beat well uh then what about
uh
what's arthur blank's patience level
after watching atlanta
um come out and still have this blowing
lead bugaboo they can't get rid of
and that's another one where there's no
way that this is going to be the same
thing they can't just roll
the balls out there again in 2021 and
say we've
we've fixed it now but but this has been
an inelastic relationship right i mean
there's numerous times where if you just
looked at this
as a non-emotional non-sentimental
non-human relationship and just looked
at the results
your mind would have said hey we gotta
go in a different direction like hey
yeah i mean now we're two and nine in
september the last three years like i've
seen this movie before
but but let you know that that same
rational decision was there for him to
make it the bye week last year and he
didn't make it
and he didn't make it again after the
season so that's another one where at
some point it will happen at some point
he'll talk to a confidant
or he'll go to bed one night and he'll
wake up in the morning and say i can't
do groundhog day anymore
but it obviously wasn't this monday you
know
it wasn't it wasn't today and that was
another
epic debacle finding ways to lose
so again because of the pandemic you
know
because of not having a normal training
camp and all that stuff
i think we'll probably see fewer moves
in general when we get to january
and maybe even fewer in season because
we got enough
unsettling stuff we're doing zoom
meetings we got enough craziness going
on here already
but at some point by 2021
i can't imagine the jets and the falcons
don't have a new head coach jason thanks
for the call um
we'll see you on sundays on cbs and then
where can people find you
throughout the week jason uh they can
find me on the
radio.com app if you want to check out
inside access
on 1057 the fan in baltimore from two to
six and you can find me on the cbs
sports network and pretty much uh daily
on cbs
sports hq so you're the man i'm around
thanks brother appreciate you right back
at you that's jason locking for
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here